our guys from the baltimore orioles
please we can barely play baseball we
need you to play spoiler good thing this
year the delaware clams are unlimited
what what does that mean like
breadsticks
[Music]
as coach of the clams i know it may take
us a decade to be ready let's try even
though it doesn't matter
okay first up everyone stop getting
distracted by davis mills first up spoil
the dolphins i'm so proud of us we're
finally a team hi miami it's little old
russell wilson perhaps you could trade
for me
then we take on the colts all right then
it's easy we've eat the jags and we're
in the playoffs sleep well
carson
do something wacky
i've had a vision then we finish off the
browns
huh guess the browns took care of
themselves hey how are the fans in new
york don't come they're so mean then we
celebrate with a photo headquarters
breached prepare to clam up
give me one good reason why i shouldn't
bite off every one of your [ __ ] eyes
washington air steamy teeny white chaos
[Music]
this truth won't last forever timmy i
will end you
already dead men watching they're going
to get real mascot soon only i get to
kill you here rock my word the only
thing the washington football team will
be renamed it's the delaware clam